Hey remember this unicorn. We're going
to talk more about set up and pay off
A couple days ago I got this comment in
response to the Suicide Squad review, so
let's quickly do a clearer dive into
what's really the essence of setup and
pay off. Now in the previous video I
mentioned the rule of threes where an
element will be set up then there's a
reminder and then finally a payoff. This
idea meshes with another dramatic
principle of Chekhov's Gun. Anton
Chekhov was a prolific Russian author
and playwright in the mid late eighteen
hundreds. He believed strongly in
narrative efficiency and thought stories
should have formal rules of construction
which is why we have the phrase
Chekhov's Gun. Remove everything that has no
relevance to the story. If you say in the
first chapter that there is a rifle
hanging on the wall, in the second or
third chapter it absolutely must go off.
If it's not going to be fired
it shouldn't be hanging there.
The unicorn in Suicide Squad is unusual, it's an
absurdist element, it breaks from
expectations, and thus definitionally
calls attention to itself
This is why we, or at least I, expect
something to come of it.
Now let's go back and look at that
comment. Wouldn't the title card be the
intro when we first see it the reminder
and then the fight the payoff? Now the
comment makes a critical error in
evaluating the rule of threes which is
holding too tightly to the idea of three
The idea isn't just that something
should show up three times but as per
Chekhov's gun it should do something
Even though the unicorn appears or is
referenced three different times
none of these actually come to anything
Three is really just a convenient number
it has a good rhythm and once something
has happened three times in a row we
instinctively start to feel like it is
intentional rather than random. Three is
indicative of a pattern. Even simpler
than the psychology of patterns though
is just basic information juggling:
managing the human memory. If someone is
watching a movie or a play or television
they're actually taking in a lot of
information at a more or less constant rate for
upwards of several hours. The reminder
stage of the rule of threes is really
just about helping the audience keep
track of something set up in the first
20 minutes if it's not going to be relevant
for another two hours. If the span of
time between setup and payoff is much
shorter then there's no need for a
reminder because it's still fresh in the
audience's mind
while if the time between is much much
longer then either you'll need more
reminders or you'll just need to spend
more time embedding it in the
audience's memory. But even that still
isn't getting to the heart of the issue
and to do that we're going to take a
look at an episode of The Simpsons.
Season three, Bart's Friend Falls in Love
centers around Bart and Milhouse having
a falling out over the new girl in class
At the start of the episode Milhouse shows
Bart his new magic 8-ball, they ask it
several questions, and the 8-ball
predicts that they won't be friends by
the end of the day.
Sure enough Milhouse falls in love with
Samantha, the new girl in class.
Bart resents the change in his
relationship with Milhouse and the two
have a falling out the culminating Bart
stitching on Samantha to her father who
has her transferred to a private girls'
school. Feeling guilty about the grief
he's caused Milhouse, Bart confesses to
Milhouse and Milhouse attacks him. Bart
grabs the eight ball and hits Milhouse
in the head breaking it
So this is all over within a half hour
including commercial breaks so there's
not really any pressing need for a
reminder, just the setup and the payoff.
The setup is that the introduction of
the eight ball into the relationship
heralds the forming of a rift, while the
payoff is that the violence and
destruction of the eight ball marks the
healing of that rift. A peaceful, friendly
interaction with the eight ball moves
the emotional state into chaos; a chaotic
violent interaction moves the emotional
state into peace. The eight ball being
used for its intended purpose brings
discord, brings a prophecy that dooms the
protagonists, and the destruction of the
eight ball, using it as a weapon breaks
the curse and breaks the power of the
eight ball over the relationship.
the writer could have used anything for this
gag but by using the 8-ball it forms an
emotionally satisfying loop which is the
essence of payoff. A stuffed unicorn
flying out of Boomerang's jacket isn't
emotionally satisfying